10750 € c'est le montant récolté par la
marche plaisiroise octobre rose destiné
à l'association à chacun son évereste
l'association accompagne des femmes en
rémission d'un cancer du sein en leur
proposant des séjours ces fonds ils vont
servir à continuer à pouvoir entretenir
le logement continuer à pouvoir les
accompagner dans leur séjours payer la
nourriture payer le fonctionnement de
l'association tout simplement isation
inédite c'est la première fois que la
ville organis une manifestation sportive
pour cette cause on a fait un appel à la
population pour organiser des marches ou
des courses à pied et on a pratiquement
1000 inscrits à quelque chose près donc
c'est fabuleux parce que tout le monde
est venu des grands des petits des
jeunes du rose en veux-tu en voilà parmi
les participants des adultes des enfants
des hommes mais surtout des femmes dont
certaines ont été atteintes de la
maladie elles sont venues pour soutenir
moi je suis très sensible au cancer
parce que j'en ai moi-même eu un et
beaucoup de membres de ma famille ont eu
et il y a quelques semaines maintenant
on m'a dit que c'était terminé j'avais
plus de concert donc c'est pour ça que
je suis là et c'est pour ça que mes
copines sont là les dons sont toujours
possible via le site de la ville de
plaisir